[Music]
it's that this our movement you have to
think about it differently
I'm going to create a relationship
between your arms so that when when my
elbow moves I don't want to Brooke
angles see my arms energies here you see
that or stay there stay there or
disapproved angle you see this one it's
not my abilities of or relation so keep
this and all I'm really doing is turning
my elbow up his elbow is going to go
through
I'm just changing the relationship
[Music]
no open space and you can see it's a
commission you know because I get the
wait go back
so the first way is on that foot on this
grab foot on the drop boom and then I
projected by moving
so you're not doing like this you have
to pin the first leg in front of the
projection throw you just did you see I
keep pushing on that line
I'm going to do I'm going to take off
pressure off of that line I'm going to
do that by moving the hand this way then
I get the Kazushi without the projection
so I'm here woman moves over and my body
moves in so everything is the same we'll
just move it over and it would lead to
that boy you just create it over
so you're creating that angle you see
the angle oh right that's the Kazushi
angle and then your spirit right through
the center of it so your ego is not a
matter of arm wrestling you're going
right to the center of it boom right it
right and we follow the principles up
I'm aiming a following body these day
he's falling and I'm aiming so just
don't finish the technique we're just
working on this sweetie that boy
stepping in
[Music]
so I can't see too far gone dead centers
actually closed you know you could just
do that wait we're looking at something
different
I want to pin him I want the benefits of
pinning training so my body has to be
able to move move in I can't have the
delays some of the things that delay you
is bad weight distribution in the up
things is shift at the wrong time to get
the movement going the other thing is
you didn't create the opening he's
pinning you now you see that which is
what a good kid should do and he creates
a reason for reconciling the energy so
you have to be able to get it all in
there every everything just goes right
in so the first movement is almost like
to push you've not yet triangular
his displacement the arm stays on the
inside is you want to have the center
line you want him to have to go to the
outside another thing is the appealing
your hand off as you're reaching from
over here so you're trying to go this
way but you got Maskull on the other way
you're reaching over here right and
remember that he had a he had a pinning
there's a pinning capacity that's why
there's a projection capacity and so
here that's a lot of weight to take off
and that's a very small muscle that's
not Q on either that's just bad like you
so this no that doesn't translate into
anything you're not going to learn
carrying striking those hand movements
don't have anything because this stuff
is so fixed that kind of stuff right
then this hand with the IDI me stays
with my hips and as I start to move
because the other hip is coming forward
there's a rotation do you see that it
doesn't stay here now I'm having this
caddywhompus body alignment you see that
good so as my hip starts to move it
should keep in this relationship and
that's what's making him me come out of
his grid not me he laid his hand up so
I'm pushing through that
yeah push through it with your bass then
I just take energy off my as soon as I
loosen it I start moving it around me I
don't want to push on it anymore I'm
gonna loosen it around me now some of
you I want to eat you know where you're
going to shove his elbow down you're
gonna have to be bigger and stronger
than him
this his elbow is gonna go down noting
his elbow in space and you tell me if it
goes down or up it went down so I'm not
pushing his elbow down I'm
deconstructing his face so I don't need
this here it's gonna go around me this
allows me to walk in it if it's in front
of me and I'm pushing it and slowing me
down so I keep moving around me outside
I keep moving it around me to take
energy off and I'm just following it now
[Music]
won't follow it following it
let the descent of his deconstructed
bass do what I needed to do do you see
that difference so I'm exaggerating I'm
not pushing you just as the caveat
that's not right hey you lost in that
hey that'sa overextension
thank you soon he's gonna fall and I'm
just following his elbow okay let's take
it to the next step go okay okay so a
little tactical all right so here I am
prioritizing deviation and Kazushi said
Mike you can see that I'm firing the
throwing angle so when I come in for the
pin I'm gonna prioritize his base over
his arms control base control over arm
control say this this I should never do
this so I'm just looking for the elbow
and just so I can go in and get rid of
that so you can see like right here you
understand where I'm wrestling with his
arm it's 50/50 so this is very important
that you get this elbow out of the way
and go right into the base okay then
what happens though is you can't
the scary unconsciously kids they roll
out of it that's not a bad things what
I'm trying to say you can you get done
hey cool
now I have room to drop my weapons stomp
on his face you get it but what stops
the rolling isn't you holding him it's
you staying up with him you see how I'm
doing that so if you look at you're
looking at it wrong you're like he's
rolling on me and you're going to
control the elbow that's actually what's
causing the roll is the disconnect he
can't do it so you need to do two things
one I need to stay up with him then del
bubble
past the top apex because I'm not on the
other side of the apex I'm at the apex
then the second thing is this is not a
dead arm go ahead and roll come back
this is a live arm so it's not shoving
him down but you can't pick it up do you
see that so some of you got our arm that
looks like to extend it but it doesn't
have any energy in it and so it doesn't
work at the apex point so if these two
things right stay up with it stay up
with it everybody it's an alive arm okay
let's go
says strike goes right to it in his
folly and I just stay up with it it's
folly leaving it around
so let's stop at that one point so let's
get to where we were here right and I'm
here right there's a little bit more
like this and I have that pin on his
shoulder if you see that right okay I
can't go any more but that's why it's a
check all right if I could go like this
he could come to me you see
so you'll hit another contention point
energy going against energy so that's
what I take around you think so I just
stay up with that small stay up with it
and it's going to fall and I just keep
connection keeping connection boom boom
[Music]
so Cheers you can tell just like on the
hand work you know you're in the right
place where if you let's go boom you can
go right to the face that's like kind of
spatial cute now you'll have that at the
bottom shoe right here boom you see
where right you can kick that's going to
tell you I'm at the energy contention
point right if I go like this let me fix
my foot you see all right let's try it
all the way then okay further for those
that are giving the pattern but it's
still eluding you you your eat your work
on your grounding party you keep seeking
bracing angles bracing angles right so
I'm gonna have extreme absence of
bracing angles okay so I'm over here and
I would want you to push back at me like
it doesn't matter weird which put yes
bracing angles bracing angles just keep
walking
instead you're grounding grounding
raising this is how they get away from
you
he's still jacking up with me right and
you can see how I think you keep pushing
on it you can see that I can keep going
so I just do that I'm doing that into
the technique